well quickly map Terry was he was the
perfect writing companion for me anyway
because he was very Terry worked hard he
made sure he got the work done and I've
been a slightly lazy apart and I
benefited from his anything his
inspiration all that he's also the
wonderful after after work partner he
loved to drink I'd love to go around to
have a pint talk about lots of other
things when I first met Terry and the
Beatles were just sort of breaking and
we used to queue up every every time a
new Beatles album came out we were the
first to queue up to buy it so little
things like that but I remember it was a
great companion Terry great companion I
think we made each other laugh great
thing about having a writing team the
two of you is that you know you bounce
one thing off the other and you could
tell if something hadn't worked because
there was no laughter I mean both of us
were very highly attuned to humor and
laughed quite easily so we didn't get a
laugh that was at them at the bottom of
the pile so you usually yes because we
had a shared sense of what was funny
which was kind of more I would say the
whimsical sort of stuff more spike
milligan than David Frost we shared that
sort of taste Indian humor and yeah we
moved just chuckle a lot as we worked
well he was so convincing as his mother
and basically that's what them the woman
character was really and Terry's mother
was a lovely lady kind of very straight
sort of feet on the ground but had this
rather nice reflective thing so that
came out and then Terry sort of
exaggerated her a bit for Mandy in the
life of Brian turned it a bit more of a
Harrington and all that but he seemed
very very comfortable inside a certain
kind of woman I don't think he Eric Idle
did the sort of glamorous drag John
Cleese did the so frightening drag and
Terry was the most convincing yes he was
really really good at that but he could
hear Terry was a great performer he
couldn't conjure up all sorts of
different characters and physically he
was a very very skilled
very skilled performer remember the one
sketch he did which involved him playing
Tchaikovsky's 1812 on escaping from a
sack three padlocks and some chains and
Terry did this thing rolled in and he
managed to get his hand that played the
piano on Bom Bom then loosen it a bit
bong bong bong Martin after 35 seconds
he was out of the sack and Dada and it
looked really really good but it was
incredibly dangerous thing to do rolling
about crashing around and missing his
footing and all that he did it superbly
I used to write with Tyrion and he had a
house in Black Prince wrote was John in
Waterloo and they were this was 1966-67
we were writing for the frost report and
they just built these new public toilets
at the end of Lambeth walk and they
wanted a local dignitary to help open
them and they didn't have anybody parked
and Terry they heard of some writers
living there
so Terry myself well-well escorted out
to open the new toilets on Black Prince
Road and be the first to use that we
went in Luther a band playing outside
and we went in and with the mayor I
think was also at the arrivals with us
and I couldn't couldn't do a thing I'm
afraid it was quite overcome and we
laughed a lot of that for a long long
time but there me one yeah there are
many many things that I I do remember
about DHL and in the days to come I
don't doubt that I shall be able to sort
of reflect on them